la région ile-de-france au soutien de
l'usiné renault de flins lors de sa
visite la présidente valérie pécresse
est venue rappeler sa volonté de
maintenir la production de véhicules sur
ce site industriel une position
contraire aux annonces de la direction
du groupe
la transformation de l'activité de
l'usiné de flins consacré dans un plan
d'économies global de deux milliards
d'euros
la direction de renault a un projet là
un projet basé sur l'économie circulaire
qui est un projet très intéressant mais
qui doit se conjuguer avec la volonté de
tous les élus du territoire de continuer
de produire des voitures ici à flins
alors la région va essayer de faire tout
ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
convaincre l'état qu'il ne faut pas d
industrialiser la vallée de la seine
actuellement la nissan micra et le
véhicule électrique zoé sortent chaque
jour des lignes de production de l'usiné
créée en 1952 l'établissement emploie
près de 2600 personnes
la région souhaite participer à sa
compétitivité et à son attractivité
la région pourrait intervenir pour
rénover complètement la centrale
thermique du site qui est vétuste et qui
pourrait se transformer en une belle
centrales de production d'énergie
peut-être même pour le territoire
durant cette visite valérie pécresse a
rencontré les partenaires sociaux des
syndicats engagés actuellement dans des
négociations avec la direction du groupe
madame pécresse on la sent très investis
c'est une personne qui veut vraiment
faire bouger les choses et qui veut
vraiment perdre préserver l'emploi et la
région le maintien de la production de
véhicules notamment du véhicule
électrique véhicule propre et quand même
un des véhicules les plus vendus sur la
région parisienne
l'état la région les pouvoirs publics
draine des milliards d'argent public
dans les poches de renault et renault
annoncent la fermeture de sites
la suppression de postes l'arrêt de
fabrication de voitures à flot et c'est
une nouvelle réunion entre les
partenaires sociaux et la direction du
groupe est prévue courant septembre pour
faire un point sur la restructuration